more than six million people living in
the Miami metro area were spared from
the storms full force but the city still
suffered serious flooding in hurricane
force winds cost at least two massive
construction cranes to collapse and
officials were worried about that the
whole time mark Strassmann is in
downtown Miami for the latest mark good
morning good morning many of this city's
streets are now fields of debris with
toppled trees and downed power lines and
some of the most conspicuous damage
you'll see here is right in the heart of
downtown Miami
this symbol of Miami's economic growth
became one of the city's most
high-profile storm victims Sunday
morning a construction crane on top of a
new 30-story building snapped under
winds nearing 100 miles per hour a
little over an hour later a second crane
collapsed a few miles north in the
Edgewater neighborhood where Lincoln
O'Berry lives these cranes that are 45
50 stories up if they fall they have the
potential to go 3 or 4 blocks and
everyone in that area should have been
evacuated
a third crane up the coast in Fort
Lauderdale also crumpled in Emmas winds
authorities in all three accidents say
there were no injuries but they won't
start a full assessment of the damage
until later today
elsewhere in Miami gusts ripped the roof
off this building fire officials say no
one was injured here either
Miami's high-end Brickell neighborhood
took the brunt of the Hurricanes
estimated 4 to 6 foot storm surge
downtown ritzy Brickell Avenue became
Brickell River we're feeling these
effects and the eyes that that is
blowing my mind on Sunday
Miami authorities had to contend with
more than eight hundred ninety thousand
households losing power in addition to
flooded streets and toppled trees and
police arrested at least 28 people for
burglary and looting with numerous
incidents caught on camera daylight is
giving everyone the first good look at
Emma's impact I want to show you a live
picture now of one of those collapse
construction cranes this is the one in
the Edgewood neighborhood the city had
25 different cranes that was worried
about that it could collapse during
Irma's winds two of them in the end did
collapse and now have to be addressed
one of the many ongoing issues here
Irma's impact also had an effect at
Miami's International Airport flooding
will close that import again today it
will reopen tomorrow applying a limited
schedule charlie mark thanks